and laura i mean how close are we to
being able to go and sit cheek by jowl
in a theater again and
rustle our bag of minstrels that is the
big question and that's why
this program was set up really so this
is the first phase of it which took
place
in april and may and involved 10
organized events
in different cities in london in
sheffield and also in liverpool
clubbing events big sporting events as
well some indoor some outdoors some
seated some not seated the idea being to
have a real
range of situations of these big mass
gatherings to see
and try and identify some of the risks
and then look at what could be done to
mitigate those risks if we look at some
of the findings in more detail at some
of those events
at the circus night club which is the
one that took place in liverpool it
hosted nearly 7
000 people over two nights ten coveted
cases were recorded
the world snooker championship in
sheffield where there were more than ten
thousand attendees over 17 days saw
six coveted cases and at the brit awards
where
three and a half thousand people
attended at london's o2
arena there were no cases recorded
there so i think lots of things to look
at from this report like i say it's only
phase one this was at a time in april
and may where
there wasn't as much mixing going on
outside but these events were really
popular
lots of people taking part lots of
people enjoyed themselves and the hope
is
that they can look at some of the
situations and pinch points as they put
it and
use that as a basis for trying to
organize future events
more safely now we know some of the
pinch points which are identified
particularly these
large unstructured events like the
clubbing event in liverpool you can see
there
the pinch points really were around
things like the entrances the exits the
toilets food and drink outlets as well
and so the idea is we can try and see
where the pinch point is and look as i
say
other things that might be happening and
how we can deal with that of course
there are big events coming up with the
euros in london as well
uh coming up very soon lots of questions
about that number of
people attending those events but it
really the scientists say is going to be
down to
local teams on the ground to look at the
sorts of people who be coming look at
the situation
where they're going to be sat down and
try and work out how best to mitigate it
but of course
for not just sporting events but for
several in the entertainment industry
this is what they've been wanting to
hear that
these events can take place can take
place safely that it doesn't bring about
any more spread of covert than
than is what was going on automatically
in in the community
and that really there's no reason
perhaps that these events can't take
place uh
in as covert compliant away as possible
in the future